hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my for readers who asked me
to check out his blog so he wrote in
saying I've been running my blog for
three years it's not been easy initially
but now the positive feedbacks I've
received for me to somewhat reassuring
please kind of take a look on the
signature let me know so how can we
improve this block let's go check it out
so at first glance it's a little
overwhelming so the the pronunciation is
quest techie quest techie okay trends in
internet technology I think here this is
a little bit hard to read this transient
technology and i'm also not entirely
sure what you do so is it are you like a
techcrunch or what's the goal of the
site i might invest a little bit of
money in creating a better logo and a
slightly better design you can do
something easily 99designs or just get a
premium wordpress theme or even a free
wordpress theme to upgrade this design a
little bit so it looks a little nicer
but definitely on the logo on the on the
tag line just to make that a little
easier to read and better explain what
you do so terms of the blog going to
make sure there's regular content so
let's see how we're doing here so jun 14
jun 9 jun 7 jun 6 that's pretty good May
31st so a couple posts per week is
what's going on here pretty good a lot
of people have a hard time maintaining a
regular schedule so it's good that
you've kind of started doing that let's
click on a sample post to see what
you're talking about here so John good
reading through this post is really
short so you could have a hard time
getting these ranked this looks like
maybe 200 250 words you want to
definitely write longer post at least
twice side look
500 words plus it makes it a lot easier
to try to get your content ranked so I
would definitely look at increasing
length of all all the posts that you're
you're writing on your website let's
read a little bit more about who you are
so it's a combination request and techy
good okay technology geek information so
Nigerian web service company specialized
in article marketing ads placements okay
so what I would say if you're going if
you're if you're focusing on article
marketing advertising your market the
stronger side marker is going to be in
North America so you want to look at
content that's going to be interesting
for North American readers and also I
guess you know England Australia
european english language but the north
american dad market is going to be your
strongest and also the largest
demographic so def and look at adding
more content that is of interest for
North American readers we've got here
it's a vehicle through which the
in-house analytics that quest techie
will express their view across the
various facet of web technology
innovations or research material for
decision-making and channel for
monitoring implementations new trends
that's a mouthful that is hard to
understand I'd have to read that a
couple times is to really figure out
what it is that you're doing here and
what I would probably do is if you're
trying to target the North American
market I would get writers who are North
American who can write in the North
American language that that they can
understand easily it's not that it's
necessarily grammatically incorrect it
just doesn't flow very well and it's
hard to understand exactly what you do
so I'm coming to your website and I'm
clicking on about us and potentially
want to hire you I want to quickly
understand what it is that you do and
how I'm going to benefit and I'm not
getting that here so again the content
should be ideally written by somebody
from North America or who's studied in
North America or lube dinner
America so they can maybe increase the
effectiveness of your copy a little bit
if your target as well is going to be
article marketing and advertising you
should be writing a lot more content and
maybe you have in the past maybe this is
just a slump that your reign in terms of
your schedule but having a couple posts
a week that makes it hard to earn a
living off of you got to be posting lots
of content up there and having a team so
it's not just you putting the content
maybe you do already but you got to be
creating a lot more content because it's
hard to get the return on investment
just from advertising from a few
articles a week so i definitely look at
ramping up the the words so 500 words
plus and also the posting frequency at
least once a day if not you know five
ten times a day and creating different
sections that makes it easier to sell
advertising so hopefully that helps fill
those of you watching if you liked the
video and you want to see more just like
it please give it a thumbs up helps keep
me going and want to make more these
videos for you and if you have a comment
about this website or question about
your own feel free to leave it in the
comments section below and we'll see you
on the next episode
you